good morning Hank it's Tuesday May 5th
2015 your 35th birthday it's just
ridiculously beautiful he ranked oh look
at time Hank is of course using this
occasion to snapchat don't rock
yes gonna ruin the shot oh it's gonna
make people sick to their stomachs see
when your birthday falls on a Tuesday it
is a great present to me because it
means I don't have to make an extra
vlogbrothers video thank you well if you
could work out that for me on August 27
oh my god you've hurt my feelings let's
move on it's to August 23rd I don't even
want to be your friend anymore but alone
your sibling I have not gotten you a
formal present instead I want to tell
you that I will get you anything you
want
I want a whole mountain I cannot buy you
a mountain I don't have the resources
what about a project it depends on the
project I don't want to do a project
that I don't want to do what's right but
it is your birthday John Green doesn't
want to do things he doesn't want to do
I have the long-standing opposition to
doing things that I don't want to do
I've wanted to do a podcast with oh I
like podcasts what should it be about
stuff that we care about stuff that we
like that's gonna bore people I really
like high concept podcasts like night
Vale or the de George's have that
podcast that's from the perspective of a
cephalopod it's a giant squid yeah yeah
do you want to ask oh oh yeah what
should we make a podcast about by the
way I don't know why we're not making
our video with that in the background I
mean I could explain it than to do with
faceted with lighting lighting so as
Hanks birthday present I am going to get
him a podcast that we bring us it's
starring us but you guys tell us what it
should be about I like the idea of I
just have this one okay
what if every episode we just talked
about a different person but we pick a
name and we just talk about a person
with that name oh so like in history oh
so it's like the steve podcast with john
and hank green yeah we're like the
sidney podcast like something
gender-neutral but it should be to name
so that people are extra confused Oh
like the Sydney and Jesse podcast with
John and Hank Brown and Hank green and
we just talked about Sydney's and
Jesse's but there should be another if
there should be no yes segments where we
talk about other stuff we're into and
also what's going on in our lives I
think all do like this week in AFC
Wimbledon like what's going on in the
fourth year involved in that everyone is
well what is something that you care
about I can do Mars cuz I've cared about
that this week in Mars and AFC Wimbledon
the Mars is so much more interesting
than AFC one
so everyone will listen for Mars we have
to do I didn't see woman first so people
have to sit through it to get to the
Mars news
strongly disagree Mars is a planet that
humans can't inhabit AFC Wimbledon is a
club made out of humans and aren't
humans the most interesting thing in the
world really he says as he points the
camera just at himself whose birthday is
it anyway it's my birthday right
isn't it August 27th or 22nd no one can
remember I'm not sure it's sustainable
are there enough soldiers named to
Sydney's didn't my mom Sydney green
Sydney Australia Oh is there a Jessie
Australia if you like this idea let us
know some Sydney's and Jesse's and
comments oh no it's it's leaving me was
that your blue steel on three our best
blue steel one two three so we need you
to tell us what our podcast is gonna be
about if it's gonna be about Sydney's
and Jesse's some Sydney's and Jesse's we
can talk about who has the best blue
steel and if AFC Wimbledon or Mars is
more important would the earth be
different if there were no Mars I mean
yes how we the sky would look different
at night but if there were no AFC
Wimbledon the core of human history
would change so also for my birthday
yeah
I have to make a video in this week yes
I wouldn't make like to make that video
of vlogbrothers Olympics I mean we
wouldn't I compete in in events how many
events 20 no it's gonna be a dodeca
Catalan no what about like a no like a
cept a salon or maybe a quadriga con ok
quadriga con i will go for so we're
doing a for event quad drag ik oh no no
no fourteen quadriga con is 14 obviously
the first event is who wins that blue
steel ok ok hey copy birthday I will see
you now continue to see you after I turn
off the camera